there's a lot of talk about the expected
rise of immigrant detentions and
deportations under President Trump so
while recently on assignment in Arizona
I visited a privately run for-profit
detention center named Eloy I had heard
a lot of negative things about Eloy
before going in that the medical care is
an adequate the food is horrible and
that it's the deadliest detention
facility in the country with at least 15
deaths since 2003 so what is the place
like Eloy even exists and why are
immigrant detention facilities like Eloy
privately run I'm Deena this is a j+ and
we're bringing you the story of how
locking up immigrants is a big business
get this the Department of Homeland
Security relies heavily on private
facilities for at least 65% of the
people they detain and they're set to
play an even bigger role in Trump's
detention expansion now private prisons
and privately run detention facilities
have already received widespread
criticism for their operations which
have no public oversight or
accountability the abuse is reported in
them were so concerning that in 2016 the
Obama administration decided to
significantly reduce and eventually
eliminate the use of private prisons
altogether they even said quote they do
not maintain the same level of safety
and security
in other words private prisons are less
safe and more expensive than those
managed by state and federal governments
I should note that President Obama's
order applied to private prisons not
immigrant prisons or detention
facilities now these are all actually
distinct but there is some overlap and
who gets detained where and they're
mainly run by two companies core civic
and geo group but before the shift could
take effect the Trump administration
reversed this policy and recommitted
federal funds to private prisons I'll
explain in a bit why this matters
especially now but first let me give you
a better sense of just how bad these
private prisons that are locking up
immigrants actually are at least 137
people died in immigrant only prison
since 1990
eight a report by the Nation magazine
found that people in these prisons
frequently suffer through painful
symptoms and died of treatable diseases
and these facilities are so unsafe that
in some cases detainees actually request
that they be put in solitary confinement
so they can be protected from other
inmates even the ACLU noted how private
facilities have quote a particularly
grisly track record of detainee abuse
and neglect
Eloy where I went is a prime example of
that and for perspective there are about
1500 people housed there the ACLU has
been calling for the closure of Eloy
specifically because of its repeated
preventable deaths it's just one of
about 46 privately run detention
facilities in the US and unfortunately
it's not the only one that's raised red
flags so given all these issues with
private prisons and privately run
detention facilities why would the new
administration keep them open
well core civic the company that runs to
Eloy gave a quarter of a million dollars
just for trump's inauguration
celebration and both core civic and geo
group the other major player in private
prisons have seen upticks in their stock
valuations since Trump has taken office
in fact core CITIC had an immediate jump
in stock the day after the election it's
up a total of 120 percent and geo has
seen an increase of 80 percent that's
because the cost of trumps expanded
deportation plans is estimated at over
80 billion dollars and could impact as
many as 11 million people anyone who is
undocumented in the country is at risk
of being deported and people trying to
cross the border are now set to be
detained for longer periods of time
under Trump's changes meaning there's
now a sudden need for more detention
facilities where immigrants can and will
be held for longer periods of time so
despite the little accountability and a
record of premature deaths and
substandard medical care it seems will
still be locking up more and more
immigrants and privately run facilities
hey guys I hope you learned a little bit
more about immigrant detention in these
private facilities if you want to see
more from my reporting in Arizona and
Mexico on immigration make sure you
check out our series and of course make
sure you like subscribe and comment
below